merci la parole et à monsieur yves
foulon merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre disons le
clairement en matière d'emploi la france
est totalement à l'envers de ses
partenaires européens en 2015 en france
le chômage a explosé alors que dans le
même temps il a baissé dans beaucoup de
pays en europe et je veux rappeler
quelques chiffres pour en être conscient
- 104 1000 chômeurs en allemagne - deux
cent trente neuf mille chômeurs au
royaume-uni - 350 4000 en espagne et
moins quatre cent soixante dix neuf
mille en italie chez nous malgré vos
promesses
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage
n'est pas au rendez vous et depuis
l'élection de françois hollande en mai
ce sont près de cinq cent mille chômeurs
supplémentaires qui ont franchi la porte
de pôle emploi toutes catégories
confondues le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi s'élève à 6 millions 500 mille
personnes
ce chiffre est bien évidemment très
éloignés des trois millions cinq cent
mille affichée par votre gouvernement
qui a l'art de manipuler l'opinion en
incluant les catégories b c d e et
l'outre-mer qui n'ont jamais été compté
nos voisins européens
e.on mise en oeuvre d'ambitieuses
réformes structurelles qui clairement
ont fait baisser le nombre de chômeurs
au contraire de cela en france vous
jouez avec les statistiques en basculant
500 mille demandeurs d'emploi dans la
case en formation
d'autre part vous annoncer la création
de 42 mille nouveaux contrats aidés qui
sont des emplois précaires des emplois
publics et qui sont financés par les
contribuables et qui ne sont donc en
aucun cas une réponse au chômage
on le sait tous la vraie réponse au
chômage c'est la création d'emplois par
les entreprises de france
monsieur le premier ministre l'inversion
de la courbe du chômage ne se décrète
pas pour créer de l'emploi pérenne
il faut arrêter de matraquer fiscalement
les entrepreneurs et il faut réformer le
code du travail
allez-vous la madame myriam el khomri
ministre du travail de l'emploi de la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
yves foulon vous parler des différentes
comparaisons européennes je me permets
de vous donner quand même quelques
éléments de ce point de vue là j'en ai
rappelé tout à l'heure quelques uns mais
il me semble essentiel de rappeler qu'au
sens du bit est un demandeur d'emploi
qui ne travaillent ne serait ce qu'une
heure par mois sort des chiffres du
chômage vous comptabilisez les
catégories a b c
les catégories c est ce que vous savez
que 40% des personnes en catégorie c
sont des personnes qui sont à temps
plein mais qui aimeraient changer
d'emploi donc comparons ce qui est
comparable et notamment avec les
chiffres du bit et ces chiffres du btc
10 6% de taux de chômage
le chômage des jeunes en france a
diminué en 2015 c'est la première fois
depuis 2010 il me semble essentiel de le
rappeler deuxième chose ou parler bien
évidemment il faut deux préalables pour
que le chômage diminue
le premier préalable c'est la croissance
elle n'était qu'à 1,1 pour cent en 2015
elle est prévue à 1 5 % en 2016 donc
c'est mieux qu'en 2015
et donc ça permettra de créer plus
d'emplois la deuxième chose c'est que
l'économie crée de l'emploi
nous avons aujourd'hui un coût du
travail notamment dans l'industrie qui
est inférieur au coût du travail en
allemagne et je pense que c'est un
facteur de compétitivité également pour
notre économie
enfin vous voulez que nous comparons
donc inspirons nous de ce qui marche au
niveau européen et la question de la
formation des demandeurs d'emploi est un
sujet essentiel quand la france forme un
demandeur d'emploi sur dix l'allemagne
en forme 2 sur 10 l'autriche en forme 4
sur 10 donc oui de ce point de vue là
nous avons un problème dans notre pays
qui est que nous avons un taux de
chômage de chômage de peu ou pas
qualifiés ça ne veut pas dire que ces
personnes n'ont pas de compétences ça
veut dire qu'elles n'ont pas de qui
d'une qualification et ça veut dire donc
elle reste sur le bord du chemin et
c'est pour ça que c'est essentiel ce
plan de 500 milles formation en
direction des demandeurs d'emploi plus
laides embauche pme qui a permis déjà
seize mille demandes en moins de quinze
jours
vous le voyez une accélération et une
réforme avec un loi travail mais elle
arrivera miconazole